hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm mr leeds and today we're going to
talk about the lock down we're in a
national lockdown
and the implications how that might
affect you
as a property investor so a little bit
of back story about the
lockdown like it happened when did we
first go into it was around about march
yes 20th of march yeah in 2020 and they
told us it'll be three weeks
honestly they said it's gonna be three
weeks and i remember thinking
i think it was the second of april i
went my house was going on auction
seven houses or selling seven houses and
i'm thinking of all the time in the
world
it falls on the second of april during
this little three week
lockdown uh no the lockdown was extended
and it was extended again
always kind of be going in and out of it
yeah they needed to help out
i remember at one point was it like july
time where they were saying encouraging
people to go out
to help the economy get moving again
yeah eat out to help out
free food or home and they said and then
they stopped us they were always telling
us though
i remember them saying in october we're
going to be totally back to normal
october's when we get the stadiums are
going to open and we will think oh great
we'll be able to run our crash courses
again
but that didn't happen that got delayed
replaced by lockdown 2.0
then miraculously everything came back
in december for about two weeks
and in that two weeks we had a two-week
window and in that two weeks we ran
we put two crash courses on hundreds of
people at the first one amazing second
one
the area went into tier three yeah then
we moved it
that means tier three we moved it again
and in the end we had to do it virtually
and then everything went to tier four
five and then now we're in a lockdown
and and that's that so how long now i
mean i remember when
i remember when we were talking about it
because obviously we had all our venues
booked till the end of the year we had
stuff booked in december and we were
saying well
everyone was saying it will definitely
be out by december you know the ones
we've got in december will definitely
happen and in a way
i suppose one of them kind of did but if
you were to guess
when would you say we'll be back to
normal
you know not having i honestly think i
know i've predicted a lot of things
like last year and then when i predict
house prices by january and it's like
it's pretty much pretty much spot on
i mean this is quite it's a really tough
one to predict i don't even think boris
johnson
has any idea
of course not boris johnson doesn't have
any idea what he's going to say
tomorrow like boris talks talking about
on the monday sensei
that's like that's like the worst i
don't even think
i can't think of anyone that knows about
everyone
i know a lot we both you know a lot of
very high profile people that are behind
the scenes we know lords
you know in the house of lords i don't
think anyone knows
what's going to happen in terms of the
lockdown but here's what i want to talk
about because this is the important
thing
is regardless of whether this goes on
for another three months or another
three years
because it won't be finished in two or
three months this is going to be a
long-term thing
yeah how does it affect property
investors
well the good thing is i mean outside of
the very first
lockdown where i think even you still
did a lockdown challenge
even during the very first thought has
still made money as a player
but it was very tough it was tough you
were talking by the way now in april
when we couldn't even view houses
yeah yeah and you were doing it
virtually yeah so that was very very
tough but
other than that i can't remember how
long that was for there was a week
challenge
oh that that was oh maybe six weeks or
so yeah yeah outside of that
the property market has pretty much
stayed i mean i i do feel sorry i've got
lots of friends in other industries and
i kind of think that they're like i'm
really struggling
we're really not because we make our
money in property and it's kind of
stayed open
so i feel very lucky i mean we sent our
kids to a
private school a lot of the parents they
run their own businesses a lot of them
are really really struggling own lots of
coffee shops things like that
don't get me wrong though we've
struggled i mean cost of things have
gone up a lot
for development yeah yeah due to
shortness
supply due to also it you know things
are restricted
but but there's a lot of positive as
well though on the development side
there's been a lot of positive things
as well but there's also could there
even be an argument
for development in particular this whole
crisis i mean
they say that opportunities often occur
in crisis do you think that
if anything for development it's
actually been aided i mean house prices
have gone up
yeah um it depends on what planning
permission has been made easier
yeah i think it just depends that
there's all
wherever there's challenges it always
brings opportunities and it depends on
which side of the coin you fall in
so some of our development deals because
of the cost of things are going up it
hits us doesn't it yeah but then we've
also had other areas where it's good but
let's talk rather than too much about
development let's talk about property
investment just in general because
as you said the property market is open
when it when it was closed in april half
a million properties
transactions were paused which caused
manic i think the government have got
skin in the game
i think that the government don't want
property prices to crash i think that
um i mean as it happens we've been in a
boom
all last last year which was crazy
depending on what area you're in
if you're in london properties were
going down if you were in birmingham or
mostly
most parts of the country were going up
um i do think when furlough and stamp
duty holiday and those things end
i do think that we're going to see a dip
in a lot of areas everywhere's got its
own economy
but right now today yep how does it
affect property investors because i
don't think it affects them negatively
much at all
i think that they need to adapt so like
for example if your strategy
was holiday destinations service
accommodation
for example and you've got somewhere in
a holiday area you might be sure
i mean of course it's still open hotels
are still open it's not like you're
stopped from
doing it they're not really though
although it's like emergency only and
things like that
for work yeah so which is what most of
what service accommodation is
i'll be speaking speaking to someone the
other day who's got service
accommodation in peterborough
and they were saying they are fully
booked it's like more than than you know
it doesn't surprise me and i think that
uh my personal opinion is
most people that are affected by on the
property side
just don't know what the rule is do you
know the story of the elephant a baby
elephant it has a little rope
around his uh foot and it can't walk
away more than 10 feet
but then when it grows up it just thinks
it can't but it actually can it's the
same road
a lot of people think yeah the same
wrote it could snap it it could just
leave but it just
in its mind it's trapped i think a lot
of people in their minds they think i
can't leave the house i can't do
anything i can't but actually
if you're in our industry you can you
can go and view houses
last week i did a financial freedom
challenge do you think it's the same as
anything though it's about learning the
rules most people
don't know the rules correct that was
property with anything
like when you actually look at the
government website and read through it's
like ah
you hear the headlines it's like oh we
can't do this it's like ah we can still
do that
ah we can on a personal level don't get
me wrong it's annoying
because you can't see family and you
can't do this and that's what they've
really hit is it they've
a lot of work stuff has kind of been
allowed to continue
and what they're
imagine if you've got a restaurant
business imagine if you're like
i'm not gonna name people but i've got
some close friends
that and i've i've been trying to
encourage them to come into my industry
come into property i know i'm making so
much money in this business i'm making
so much money in this business i'm like
yeah but strategically invest your money
from your business into property in this
way no
i'm good i'm good i'm good now they're
on the verge of bankruptcy or events
there's no money in events no money in
events
we've lost money significantly with our
training company this year
and it doesn't matter yeah no because
we've got our property business
i think property has got to be one of
the safest
uh things to invest people whatever have
people need a home
yeah people you know they need somewhere
to live yeah you know it doesn't matter
what so you think the key is to learn
the rules study the rules
and adapt be prepared to adapt yeah
adapt listen this is that's probably the
biggest takeaway for me from 2020
yeah is unique the companies that
survive i see it all the time you see
little examples of companies that are
thinking outside the box you know i saw
a place
a restaurant in um a pub
in worcestershire and it was when the
pubs were bound
unless they serve food but this pub
didn't have a kitchen or anything
so they teamed up with a fish and chip
shop next door yeah and they were taking
orders
bringing in the food it's like great
well done you know you're thinking
outside the box and you're exactly
that's being an entrepreneur what are
you allowed to do right now then as a
property investor so you're allowed to
view houses you have to do everything
you've got to book viewings see houses
you're allowed to meet up with
solicitors and sign the contracts you
have anything to do with buying a house
i'm going to stay i ran an estate agent
the other day and i said
hey can i meet up and have a chat with
you i want to go through what i'm
looking for and they said well
you can't come to the office i said okay
well what could we do i said well
you know well i guess um i guess we
could meet at costa
um down the road now this was before the
full national lockdown this was this was
a couple of weeks ago but even today
though it's about
don't focus on what you can't do just
think how can i what's the
zoom as well i mean how blessed have we
been with zoom can you imagine if this
had happened
20 years ago before any of this
technology was available we had dial up
internet and stuff it would have been
enough yeah
so what are your final words then to
people watching this because the
i think the biggest piece of advice i
can give to people is don't wait
now is not the time to say let's wait
and see what happens
it's like no in fact you're forced to be
at home right now
you can't do a lot of stuff but you can
do property
if you don't become financially free in
2021 through property it
it's never going to happen that's a
great opportunity you see a lot of
people you know
a lot of sayings if you don't manage to
achieve your goals you know
lose weight whatever it is during a
lockdown you never lack time
you lack discipline yeah that's true and
it's to say it's the same with
with property if you've if you're
interested in property if you want to
learn about property and you're stuck at
home right now
this is your chance to learn about
property this is your chance to go and
view houses this is your
hey it gets you out of the house doesn't
it i mean we got to the point because we
had to do some
rubbish tips um after christmas
loads of cardboard boxes and stuff we
had some trips to the tip and i said and
anna was like
should we go together or something to do
you know what i mean it's like this
because you can't go out
actually going to the tip was a form of
injury it's funny because so many people
aren't doing property right now because
they think they can't and the only
people that seem to be winning at the
moment are
me and our success students on winners
on a wednesday
everybody else seems to be giving up
yeah don't they so get out there
do it yeah realize you can do it learn
the rules
yeah and and now more than ever
is the time to take some ownership
because jobs
i know you've got photos and stuff but
how can people be made redundant now
more than ever is the time to
not now is the time so come down to the
crash course
get trained book viewings get out there
make it happen
if you don't become financially free in
2021 probably never
gonna happen hope you enjoyed this video
russell my brother the ceo of the
company
smash a like if you like russell cohen
on the channel also subscribe to the
channel
watch some more videos and i hope to see
you at the crash course i'll leave a
link in the description
thanks so much see you next time
you